there's no question of reconciling them
they have different jobs to do and in
before the modern period people in all
cultures understood this people knew
that there were two ways of coming at
truth one with science or what be what
the Greeks called Lagos reason logic and
the and that was it was essential that
that the discourse of science so logic
related directly to the external world
the other was mythos what the Greeks
called miss which didn't mean a fantasy
story but it expressed it was us it was
a narrative associated with ritual and
ethical practice that helped us to
address problems which there were no
easy answers like mortality cruelty and
the the sorrow that overtakes us all
that's part of the human condition and
it's you couldn't do these two were not
in opposition we needed both if your
child dies or you witness a terrible
natural disaster yes you suddenly want a
scientific explanation as to what's
happened but science can't help you to
find meaning some kind of help you deal
with that turbulence of your grief rage
and dismay a science can diagnose our
cancer and can even find the cure for it
but it can't and the air scientist will
be the first to say it can't help you to
deal with the distress and
disappointment in a terror that comes
with the diagnosis and nor can it help
you to die well like Socrates kindly not
railing against fate but in possession
of your own death and for that people
for these imponderable questions people
have turned to mythos and but the
important thing about mrs. then it's not
something you just believe a myth is
essentially a program for action and
unless you translate a mythical story or
a doctrine of the church into practical
action it just remains incomprehensible
rather like the rules of a board game
which seemed very sort of dull and
complicated and incomprehensible until
you pick up the dice and start to play
when everything falls into place and so
the early doctrines of the church even
doctrines like Trinity an incarnation
where originally also calls for action
calls for selflessness calls for
compassion and unless you put you live
that out compassionately selflessly you
didn't understand what the doctoring the
same